Okay. Chapter One.
Hmm.
Not quite right.
-Huh.
-(CELL PHONE RINGING)
What?
Why are you rewriting
the book, bozo?
Diane's version is great.
You're gonna lose gems
like this one? (CLEARS THROAT)
(HACKING, COUGHING)
Ahem.
"The only longstanding
relationship in BoJack's life
is with his agent,
Princess Carolyn.
Her loyalty must come
from a deep-rooted faith
that she's talented enough
to sustain the career of a man
society perceives as a joke."
Uh, yeah, I would say
that I'm not such a fan
of that one.
All publicity is good publicity.
That guy who killed
all those teachers
and ate their fingers?
He just got married in jail.
And when this book comes out,
you could be that guy.
Oh, don't you get it?
This is my last chance
to make people love me again.
If this goes out,
everybody's gonna see
the real me.
Now, I spend a lot of time
with the real me.
-And believe me,
nobody's gonna love that guy.
-Okay.
Now if you'll excuse me,
I need to go take a shower
so I can't tell
if I'm crying or not.
-All right, let's get to work.
-(KNUCKLES CRACK)
I feel like
we can beat this font.
Ah, Copperplate,
a font for the truly modern man.
Ha. No.
There you are, Verdana.
Oh, Comic Sans,
you drunk, go home.
3:10?
I just spent six hours
playing with fonts? Holy shit!
Well, this can't be that hard.
DIANE: BoJack often felt
the need to impress me
with material items.
You can see from the teeny,
tiny brush strokes,
that this is very expensive.
I wondered where this came from
There were two obvious suspects
His mother, Beatrice,
heiress to the Sugarman
Sugar Cubes fortune
and used to certain comforts,
and his working-class father,
Butterscotch Horseman,
who often failed
to provide those comforts.
Or, maybe
it was something even--
(MIMICS EXPLOSION)